hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to cuphead so we're
almost done with this game which means
that this might just be where the end is
Inc well hell why would I go there why
did we and mug man go there in the first
place that seems like a bad place to be
hmm alright well ended casino I go I go
hey yeah I don't like this place all
bets are off
there's no option for simple difficulty
you have to do this super strong key
well lookie here you actually pulled it
off but you've made me lose a bet and
for that you ain't seeing the boss just
yet we're gonna play a little game first
that's why which is cuz you're a shitty
person well you're making this happen
that's ain't my fault oh yes Wow
oh that wasn't a good thing was it that
Oh Oh landing good Oh
oh [ __ ] okay well this is weird [ __ ]
whoa I'm not paying attention oh jeez
oh wow okay Wow whoa this is gonna be a
doozy I can already tell this is gonna
be a doozy how about I don't what if I
don't
fine I will health up okay ah okay all
right I get it is it like a is this like
a rigmarole hold smash battle of a bunch
of different things [ __ ] goddamn it I do
not pay attention to them goddamn it I'm
not paying attention to the right things
oh [ __ ] god I've been hit by everything
Oh Rock every single thing I got hit by
every single thing Wow
that is ridiculous okay here we go
alright oh hey you're different oh jeez
just as time as I learned something I
got to learn something else huh I see
how it is well he's dead now oh I see
what I need to do that's horrible
this is horrible I don't like you I
don't like you at all at least you guys
seem to have relatively simple mechanics
hate that please tell me that's all you
do please tell me that's literally all
you do you've got no originality to you
that's it this is all there is
it's like in my bay yeah is this oh yeah
baby okay oh jeez Oh God Oh dice man
don't do that don't do that so it is a
gambit I gotta like I got a oh I see
what I gotta do okay all right one two
three one two three one two point toe oh
I see I see it is a game oh okay I get
it
oh yeah whoa I don't like this whoops
[ __ ] I don't know what this is gonna do
yeah I don't really like that one very
much oh hey baby
all right well I'm doing pretty good I
don't know what that drink one threw me
so hard it was just like it was it was
really weird it shouldn't have been that
bad okay if I can just get a one one or
a three one one one one one
yeah health up baby give it give it give
it give it give it come on what do you
got what do you got you got nothing
that's what you got you got
oh oh I don't like this guy oh thank
good okay well that's a bunch of rabbit
skulls very morbid but you know it is
why it is ha ha ha you didn't count on
the fact that I can just go ask a payout
of anything did you
ah there's man oh I just moved my camera
I'm sorry all right there we go
nobody saw anything right nobody
appeared behind the curtain no one saw
anything Davey is happening did you know
all right how about it tu-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu
toe toe it speeds up to 200 all right
how about three how about three three
three three three three three three
ah shoe three three three no three three
three no what am i doing three gray yeah
baby okay
goddamn Oh start over or fin I don't
like that at all
oh I don't like that at all oh boy yeah
I don't like you at all either whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa hey whoa whoa whoa easy
up there you lad oh well this is
ridiculous sad why is this where's this
thing so sad I don't know what to make
of this very oh I see oh I see I see oh
it's a matching game ah not quite okay
huh good thing I'm so smart oh I like
that
okay got that all right now you're dead
okay what is this god I haven't seen
that one yet
oh hey got it all right heard later well
oh whoa whoa okay what do we got here I
saw that over here nah [ __ ] it was over
here some yeah that was it you got that
[Music]
okay [ __ ] so sad the US are you over
there no no no he was up here nose down
here wasn't oh geez oh no you are there
ish okay this guy's not so bad
ah [ __ ] I say as I almost get hit okay
all right okay all right okay well we
got you and you are here yes okay there
we go there we go there we go oh I don't
like that I don't like that at all okay
there you go there you go and last
though so as slappy laughing oh boy here
gonna be super fast ain't you and super
annoying oh no you're not that fast
you're faster by far well get dead oh
that was not fun hey got a boss smash
your own ad together that you shouldn't
be doing that I mean if you want to do
that I guess I can't stop you
okay if I roll a three I'm done if I
roll a three I'm done
three three three three three
there we go that was it three three
three three
go oh oh wait wait no wait no wait
what's out oh jeez that's not fun at all
I didn't know that was gonna be
immediately going for that Oh No wow wow
wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow holy
[ __ ] - wow wow wow wow wow okay this is
gonna suck this whole thing is gonna
suck all right what do you get what do
you go oh I don't like that oh I hate
that hate that in fact why is everyone
dead at this casino also I feel like
that should be something that people are
slightly perturbed about be able to shed
me a little concerned I mean oh [ __ ] oh
god damn it any hit is like gonna be
super bad there we go okay god this is
gonna be rough rough and tumble but
that's amazing they they built however
many tiles there are bosses for this
like wow that is amazing ok 3 or 2 3 3 3
3 3 okay is some good at hitting the
dice but some tells me I'm gonna bone it
up
[Music]
[ __ ]
Oh goddamnit okay I know I had my super
there but it wasn't a good place to use
it
he was just it was really rough and
tumble okay if I get a three get a three
three three three three three three
three
okay safe 1 a 2 1 a 2 1 a 2 2 2 2 2 got
it
yeah yeah let's hope the next one
something that I can use I don't know if
I got this one last time I probably did
but nope haven't seen this one I'm gonna
play it safe with this
oh boy plates they play all right that
is all Oh what is that are you kidding
me I just happened to be standing in the
wha oh boy this is awful what oh oh boy
oh boy hate this hate this right this
okay I'm gonna use this but I don't know
how well it's gonna go ah I got hit I
got hit again I got hit a [ __ ] again
ah oh boy that was useless though so
useless oh this is a bad one to give
this was a bad one to get it's not that
bad I guess but Jesus still like oh
gross cross cross cross cross cross very
gross very gross fair ghost don't like
that ghost ghost ghost ghost is pretty
much anything is bad at this point to
get bad I get hit twice there I'm so
boned okay gotta get it too and then got
to get it to 2 and 2 to 2 got it okay
then I just can't get a 1 well let's
game for it - just in case of stoop 2 2
2 2 2 2 2 2
got it okay what no no no no no way I
had that oh my god are you kidding me
holy [ __ ] this one's gonna be [ __ ]
brutal okay Wow
alright well three three I'd have done
this one before it's just the cigarette
yeah
there we go okay first boss down first
boss down I got my super I should have
changed down my super for the other
thing but oh alright alright alright
alright alright
get it - get it - got to get it - okay
got it - okay this is fine I'll try to
do it but I don't think it's gonna do
much but might as well cuz what else am
i doing right oh no no no oh no oh
that's bad
oh that's bad that was so stupid of me I
imagine that this guy this guy probably
gives most of the players of this game
the most grief because holy [ __ ] this is
set up for a brutality oh god okay gotta
get a 3 a 3 a 3 a 2 and a 3 3 great whoo
that was almost a 2 that was almost a
two okay gotta get to now - okay got it
- I've done this one I think this is a
cube on this cube alright just got dodge
dodge dodge dodge dodge dodge dodge
dodge like the dickens dodge like the
dickens okay dodge like the dickens
I just like the directive it's easy
peasy easy people off tempo off tempo
off-tempo off tempo off-tempo off tempo
off Kendell off tempo of tempo hey okay
alright we got five health five and
there's a route where we can just get us
safe and then we can go right into the
last one even though it's [ __ ] we
all know it I know it you know it I just
can't get a three to two that would've
been one two two two
- - no no no no oh no oh no well it's
fine okay cuz most of this is clear okay
that's not so bad three it didn't reset
three three okay - got it then a three
three okay then a two - okay then at
three or two or three two or three two
or three three okay all right then just
a one I'm pretty sure it won't little me
back if I do I'm pretty sure anything at
this point is gonna be one one okay okay
that's how you do it okay that's one
health health point down oh [ __ ] god
dammit god dammit god damn he's just
bleeding me dry no nope nope [ __ ] I'm so
boned your stupid hands can cry all day
one [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah oh boy
that one took the longest so far I think
Oh 20 minutes on that bad boy oh yeah
okay be alright so I don't think I'm
gonna be able to beat the devil in this
episode so I'm going to save that for
the next episode that was an arduous
journey but it was worthy journey so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I'm gonna finish this up in one more
episode I wanted to dedicate a whole
episode to it because I don't know how
long it's gonna take if that one took 20
minutes next one might take an hour so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]